تحدث باسم الخارجيه القطريه ماجد الانصاري
ان المجتمع الدولي مطالب اليوم باتخاذ
قرار واضح لوقف الحرب في غزه فورا واضاف
انه لا يمكن التعامل مع تصاعد التوتر في
البحر الاحمر بشكل منفصل عن الحرب في غزه
واكد الانصاري ان الجهود التي تبذلها قطر
في محاوله لوقف الحرب في غزه
مستمره توسع في الحلول الامنيه ايضا هو
مشكله كما قال معالي في جلسته اليوم في في
دافس هذه المساله لن تحل بشكل عسكري امني
هي ستحل بشكل سياسي من خلال ايقاف الحرب
في غزه وبقيه هذه التداعيات ستتراجع بناء
على ذلك تستمر الجهود القطريه هذه الايام
من خلال الاتصالات مع مختلف الاطراف نحن
على امل ان يكون هناك تقدم في هذه
المفاوضات في الايام القادمه الوضع كما
تعلمون هو صعب بشكل كبير هناك جزئيات يتم
التفاوض عنها حاليا الان على امل ان يكون
هناك تطورات ايجابيه وستعلن عنا ان شاء
الله في حال كلله هذه المحاولات بنجاح